Benoit block is back for another edition
of CSI KFC or a Knives Out mystery and
the critics are sharing their thoughts
when writer director Ryan Johnson's
Knives Out premiered in 2019 it was
praised for both its Delirious humor and
its engaging take on a classic whodunit
story the film recalled some of the best
crime keeper comedy Thrillers from
decades past such as 1973's the long
goodbye and 1985's clue in addition to
Johnson's witty and inventive script
which received a 2020 Academy Award
nomination for best original screenplay
the movie's cast of characters was a
particular highlight anchored by Daniel
Craig as the engaging investigator
Benoit Blanc
in for a penny in for a pound with the
release of Glass Onion a Knives Out
mystery Ryan Johnson is returning to
what is now becoming a dark comedy
franchise on Netflix with a new setting
mystery and set of performers joining
Craig's irreverent and eccentric
detective Blanc the movie is already
winning praise from critics which are
hailing it as another dazzling entry in
the knives out Universe of movies
although audience score ratings for the
title are not available yet the film
currently has a fresh rating in the 90s
from the Critics on Rotten Tomatoes here
is what they're saying in a five-star
review for movie marker clutchianulo
concluded her review of the sequel by
stating improving that the first film
was no fluke and the depth of his
talents Ryan Johnson delivers another
passionate love letter to the murder
mystery genre losing none of its charm
and crowd-pleasing appeal it surpasses
the original and has a blast doing so
commentators have also pointed out the
movie's numerous surprises that keep
viewers guessing as to who the culprit
is with in its murder mystery writing
for the Austin Chronicle critic Trace
sever commented on the movie by saying
it's blunt but not grating a result of
Johnson's Deft Touch as a filmmaker he
toes the line of getting too gratuitous
to be fair there are maybe one too many
celebrity cameos here but there's an
infectious quality to the worlds he
builds on screen an onslaught of cameos
from famous personalities can be a
feature that becomes gimmicky as slant
Magazine's Kenji fujishima observed in
his more mixed review he wrote Such spot
the celebrity Cameo games suggests that
Johnson is far from shy about flaunting
that Netflix Budget on the screen which
to some degree undercuts the film's
attempt to take the thought of the
privileged one aspect of the film that
many critics have been United on is
praise for two of the central
performances are we even going to talk
about the elephant in the room
am I the elephant yeah you're the
elephant the performances of Daniel
Craig as Benoit Blanc and newcomer to
the franchise Janelle Monae as Cassandra
Andy brand are both being praised in
multiple reviews in his review for
timeout Philip desemlin wrote of the
film happily it also plays to its
biggest strength Daniel Craig's sleuth
for hire Benoit Blanc whose Arch manners
are a great showcase for the x007's
breezier side he offers us our polite
but unimpressible entree to its Ensemble
of largely terrible one percenters real
talks David Gonzalez truly laid on the
praise for Monet by stating similar to
Anna De armas in 2019 Chanel Monet is
downright Sensational Monet offers up a
layered and nuanced performance without
entering spoiler territory that hits the
mark in comedic and dramatic ways it's
Monet's finest performance yet and
should be in the conversation for an
Academy Award nomination Daniel Craig
and Janelle Monae as well as fellow
Ensemble members Edward Norton Kate
Hudson Catherine Han and Leslie Odom Jr
can all be seen in Glass Onion a Knives
Out mystery in theaters for only one
week starting on November 23 2022.